il est bientôt midi ce jour-là Melinda
profite de sa pause déjeuner pour faire
un petit détour
un premier questionnaire à remplir avant
de s'enregistrer auprès du médecin voilà
puis le parcours commence
Mélinda va faire son premier don du sang
d'abord cet entretien de quelques
minutes avec un médecin de
l'établissement français du sang il
vérifie sa tension lui donne quelques
indications puis direction la salle
suivante où elle retrouve une de ses
collègues
il faut faire au doigt avant
ça va un peu peur des aiguilles mais
pour les vaccins par exemple mais sinon
ça va cette collecte est organisée dans
le cadre d'un tout nouveau concept lancé
par l'Établissement français du sang
Île-de-France le challenge entreprises
une petite dizaine de sociétés de la
région y participent et accueillent une
équipe de médecins sur place pour
récolter un maximum de sang les salariés
peuvent alors faire un don directement
sur le lieu de travail
a Guyancourt Sodexo est la seule
entreprise des Yvelines participer
depuis 5 ans déjà deux fois par an le
comité d'entreprise et la direction
organise des collectes dans ces locaux
pour le FS Île-de-France ce challenge
est aussi une façon de les remercier et
de mettre en avant leur engagement ils
acceptent à la fois que leurs
collaborateurs prennent sur le temps de
travail pour venir donner leur sang ils
acceptent de faire de la promotion de la
collecte avant et à l'intérieur de
l'établissement mettant des affiches
distribuant des tracts et finalement ça
paraît tellement simple et autres sauf
que ça se fait pas systématiquement
on sait que traditionnellement en France
c'est un enjeu d'arriver d'arriver à
générer une collecte une collecte
suffisante donc on est très impliqué à
la fois par par connaissance du secteur
d'activité de la santé et aussi par
notre engagement social
une vingtaine de minutes lui ont suffi
Mélinda a terminé son don du sang j'ai
jamais eu l'occasion de le faire étant
donné enfin le cadre ou autre dans les
différents endroits où j'ai travaillé et
là c'est vraiment c'est vraiment été
l'occasion de le faire donc pas déçu et
très content donc à refaire je sais par
la suite
sur les 800 salariés de l'entreprise une
soixantaine se sont inscrits au
préalable sur Internet tandis que
d'autres viennent spontanément le jour
même une deuxième collecte sera
organisée ici en juin les résultats du
Challenge seront donnés l'été prochain